(missile whooshing)
- Joint exercises between the
US and Philippine militaries
are just wrapping up
out here in the Pacific.
And while these exercises
happen every year,
this year marked the
biggest show of force ever.
Right now, we're watching a drone fly laps
off the coast of this beach,
and behind me is an Avenger platform
loaded with stinger missiles
that are gonna take down that drone.
(missile whooshing)
- Our task is to be ready
with defensive weapon systems like this.
Certainly, this is a great
opportunity to do that
for US soldiers and our leaders.
We wouldn't be here unless
it was at the request
of our partners through the Philippines,
and it demonstrates not
only a real capability
should it be required, but
hopefully it demonstrates
to our partners a special relationship
as one of our five treaty
alliances that we have out here.
(gentle music)
(gentle music continues)
(helicopter whirring)
- These exercises are coming on the heels
of a major new agreement that's
giving the US greater access
to Philippine bases.
(fanfare music)
- [Participant] The US being the biggest
or one of the biggest players
in the West Philippine Sea.
- These efforts are especially important
as people's Republic of China
continues to advance
its illegitimate claims
in the West Philippine Sea.
(gentle music)
(helicopter whirring)
(gentle music continues)
- I'm confident that
regardless of the threat,
my responsibility is to train
our shoulders to be prepared.
We demonstrated some of
that capability out here
during this live fire.
(missile whooshing)
Our opportunity and our responsibility
and our mission is to defeat a range
of threats if those are presented.
- Following these exercises,
the president of the Philippines
is heading to the White House
to meet with President Biden
to talk about their commitment to defense
and other ways the
countries can work together
like potential economic cooperation.
(gentle music continues)